[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MOTORCYCLE ENGINE]
[END PLAYBACK]
KEN HILL: So just a quick
little video, a minute or so
of seeing what it's
like from riding
a motorcycle at that pace.
And there's a lot
going on, obviously,
when the motorcycle
is going that quick.
And today's talk, for
the next 30 minutes,
I'll get into why
riding a motorcycle
like that can work in
the rest of your life,
how the things that
we do to mitigate risk
will work in the
rest of your life.
So before I get into the
introduction to myself,
so why is motorcycle
racing important?
And why do we look
at these habits
and these techniques of what
the best riders in the world do?
And sports, all sports
have three aspects.
They have the physical aspect.
They have the mental aspect.
Well, there's also a
lot of sports that have
a mechanical aspect as well.
So when you look at-- for
instance, we take volleyball.
So volleyball is very physical.
It's mental, but there's
really no mechanical part of it
with that sport.
Then we take something
like car racing.
Car racing is very mental.
And also, it's mechanical,
but it's really not
all that physical.
What I mean physical is,
physical being that your body
movements, what you do
changes what the sport does.
And in car racing, you're
not moving your body around.
And when you get to the upper
levels of a car racing, Formula
One, Formula 3,000,
some of the forces
are the same as they
are on motorcycles.
So motorcycles has all of
those factors of that sport.
So it has the mental
side, the physical side,
and the mechanical side.
But there's one other
aspect of our sport
that also is a factor,
which is the risk.
So here in motorcycle,
you can fall down
at pretty much any time.
And of course, what we're trying
to do is to mitigate that.
So by having, or looking at what
the best riders in the world
are doing on the bike
and off the bike,
and if you can put those
in the rest of your life,
even some of these
small little things,
that's what's going to
make you successful in all
these aspects.
And one of the things
that we talk about
is, how you do anything
is how you do everything.
And we are looking at what
these professional guys, what
these guys do.
And these guys are riding
at an incredible rates.
And the competition
is so incredible.
And here, we can
look at golfing,
and we can look at basketball.
We see how the scores are
and how close everything is.
To give you an idea
in motorcycle racing,
in the last MotoGP race,
the last MotoGP race
a couple of weeks
ago, that race time
was 42 minutes and six
seconds, so 2,527 seconds.
The race was won by less
than 9/10 of a second.
So when you look at the--
you do the math of
that, so here, they
had 42 minutes, less than
3/100 of a percent difference
between these riders.
So think about these riders
riding for 42 minutes,
and they're literally at that
point on those motorcycles, ice
skating around, because
that's how these bikes are.
They're so powerful,
and they're so fast.
And to give you an
idea, for people
that aren't into
motorcycles or aren't
into motosports, motorcycles,
from a performance standpoint--
so everybody's into the fancy
cars and all that stuff.
There isn't a faster
production vehicle
other than a motorcycle,
BMW 1000, for instance.
We use that.
Dan's got one.
BMW 1000, from 0 to
145 miles an hour.
You can go down,
buy one for $15,000.
And there isn't anything
that will outperform
it 0 to 145 miles an hour,
period, Bugatti Veyron,
any of those things.
It doesn't even come close.
So the performance
aspect of these things
is just absolutely incredible.
So what these athletes are
doing at the highest levels,
and they're essentially
riding these bikes
on very small contact
patches of rubber
and being able to
not fall down--
that's, again, taking these
habits and the techniques
that they're doing to
be able to do that.
So one of our local tracks,
Thunder Hill front straightaway
speed--
Dan's bike, for instance--
about 180 miles an hour,
he's going 276 feet a second.
So think about what
your thought process has
to happen at 276 feet a second.
And then you think
about average speeds.
The average speed of
that MotoGP race there,
about 185 feet a second.
So average.
So think about how your
thought process has to work
and what they're trying
to do to mitigate that.
And what I want to
be able to do is,
I'll give you some of
these best practices,
and we'll go through
them and be able to see
if we can put some of
these in your own world,
and see if you can get
a little bit of edge
with some of the things
that you're doing
and all the other
aspects of your life.
And what it boils down
to is these riders
have basic fundamentals.
And what they're
trying to do is have
perfect execution of these
fundamentals under pressure.
Everybody can practice or train.
You see guys a lot do that.
But it's what they do
on Sunday afternoon
in front of 100,000 people
that really puts it into play.
So that's what the top
riders are going to do.
And that's how we're-- that's
how we'll take a look at it.
Races are won--
I know one of the things
that people look at,
but they may not give
enough thought to is
it really is a marathon.
It's not a sprint.
The rider that
wins the race, he's
not the rider that sets
the one single fast lap.
He's the rider that sets
the most fastest laps
over the race.
The rider that wins
the championship
is a rider that sets
the most fastest laps
over the whole year.
That's the rider that
wins the championship.
So you gotta think about it in
a little bit of the long term
and what some of
these things are.
And you have to look at
your short-term goals
versus your long-term
goals, which
we'll get into it as well.
And really what it boils
down to is the fundamentals
and how well you're
doing the fundamentals.
Motorcycling, the
fundamentals of riding,
it's actually not
that difficult. It's
got two wheels, a throttle,
and a brake, and you go ride.
And that's something that
people get really confused about
is they all think that there's
some sort of a silver bullet
for all of these things.
And there's not.
Those people that are
at the top levels,
they're just better
at the fundamentals
than everybody else.
That's it.
They're better at
perfecting the fundamentals.
So I'm going to give a little
bit of introduction to myself.
And I think having an
introduction is good.
And I think that when
you look at people
that are in your own
space, whether you're
a manager, individual
contributor with the company,
is hearing stories and being
able to look at individualism
is a pretty big deal.
And because one of the things
that we pride ourselves
on in how I teach in
the schools that I
teach is our curriculums--
the curriculums are set for
the student, not the teacher.
A lot of times,
we see curriculums
that are set for the
teacher, not the student.
So we want to be able
to conform to what
the student's needs are.
So hearing their stories and
being able to relate to them
ends up being a pretty big deal.
So that's one thing that if
people come ride with me--
and these guys, a
couple of people,
three people in this room
have ridden with me before--
is we find out what
they do for a living
and what some of
their backstory is.
So my story is one--
my name is Ken Hill.
And I ride motorcycles
for a living.
And typically, when
people hear that, they--
I have three kids.
And they'll say, you
got kids and a mortgage.
You're nuts.
Right?
You're a complete risk taker.
And the funny part is I
work at mitigating risk
probably more than every
single person in this room.
I want to go quick so when I
go to a track day or a race
day, the riders that I coach--
I'll get into that
in just a second.
The riders that I
coach, very, very fast.
I have to ride
with these riders.
So I have to ride with
some of these guys that
have won national championships,
and they're top in their field.
But I also have
to pay my mortgage
and put my kids through college.
So working at
mitigating risk, that's
really what we're looking at.
So I got started in the sport
pretty late, 30 years old.
I was in the car business.
Spent 20-some-odd years
in the car business
managing parts and service
departments in the dealerships.
And so I spent 20 years,
20-plus years, doing that.
And of course, now-- that was
a 40-hour-a-week job, kind of.
And now, I work 80 hours a week
to not work 40 hours a week.
But I'm sure you guys are
all very familiar with that.
So I got started in
this sport very late.
I didn't have a lot of
natural talent in this sport.
I wanted to do it because
I wanted to race cars.
Couldn't afford to race cars.
So I thought, I'll
do something cheap.
I'll ride motorcycles.
And when I got
into it, because I
didn't have a lot of background,
I didn't have any talent.
Right?
I didn't have any
of these things.
So I had to build technique.
So I became very
studious of our sport.
And I realized that
if I want to get good,
I have to study it because I
didn't have that background.
So I became very
technique-based in our sport.
I just did it because I didn't
have anything else to fall
on other than technique.
So as I studied the sport--
and I realized at
that time that there
wasn't a lot of
information out there
that put things in
a very simple way.
Right?
Just a lot of chatter
that was out there.
And I went through, and I
decoded it in my own language.
And as I got better
in the sport,
I won local championships.
I did my first professional
race at age 41.
I held a professional
license up till age 43.
I was top 10 in the nation
at that point at age 41.
So I was able to ride
at a very high level.
And through that, people asked
me, well, gosh, you're riding,
and you're kind of a older dude.
What can we do to--
what can I do in my riding?
And it was through that that
I developed my own language
with this sport and have
been able to communicate it.
And it's my
full-time profession.
So my riders, to
give you an idea
of where I'm at with
it, so my riders,
I have three riders
that have all
won national championships,
so best riders
in the United States.
2017, my riders have 59
podiums in national competition
as well as podiums with
regional riders as well.
And what we look at
with our riders is,
again, we take each one of
their individual attributes,
and we look at these things.
And we find out what's holding
them back in their riding.
And we look at
their fundamentals.
We build their fundamentals.
The things that I work
on, and with these guys
here that I've ridden
with, with the riders
that I work with on a
national level, no different.
Language is the same.
The technique is the same.
Just the degree of
application changes.
And I think that
that's something that's
really important when you look
at fundamental-- when you build
fundamentals, it's identifying
what the right fundamentals
are, and then through that,
making those fundamentals more
precise.
So that's really
the introduction
I just wanted to give you.
I didn't want to
make it too long.
And realize that
my riders, we want
to give them a way to
continually get better.
And we want to give them a
way that allows them to grow.
And we look at that through,
again, fundamental building,
and what's holding them back.
And there's some
cool things in here
that we're going to talk
about with our best practices.
So I'm just going to jump
right into some best practices
because that's kind of
what everybody wants
to know is, like, what
are some of these things
that these riders are doing?
What are some of these
things that these guys
are doing on the
bike and off the bike
to make them better riders,
to make them better people?
So I'm just going to
jump right into that.
And the first thing I'm going
to do is, if you can today, is
give your self permission
to learn something.
I know it sounds silly.
Give yourself permission
to learn something.
And I've been to a lot
of different talks.
I've heard a lot
of people present.
And it almost comes off to
where it's sort of beyond you.
But if you start to
read between the lines,
give yourself permission
to put this in your world.
I'm not going to leave my world,
but you say all these things,
put them into your world and
see how those things fit.
So you can give yourself
permission to that.
So first best practice
that I want to talk about,
the first thing that we
look at with our riders,
is something that you may
not have thought about.
But realize that there's
three aspects of an athlete.
And motorcycle riders,
motorcycle racers,
whether you like it or
not, you guys are athletes.
And if you can start to
look at yourself in that,
and you're at in
your job performance,
you can almost start
thinking of yourself
as a corporate athlete,
or somebody that
has to perform at a high level.
Because I know every
single person in this room
is asked to put out as much as
they possibly can all the time.
So the three aspects
of an athlete are one,
it's your technique
and your craft.
It's what you do.
It's all the things that
you do through the day.
Right?
All the discipline
that you've learned,
the education that you've got.
Right?
That's the number one thing.
Well, the second
aspect of an athlete
is their physical fitness.
So the more physically
fit they are,
the longer they can
access their technique.
So as soon as your
fitness drops--
if you're out on
a motorcycle race,
or whether you're a cyclist,
or whatever it may be,
as soon as your
fitness drops, you
lose the ability to
access your technique.
You're not going to
be able to access
your technique at a high level.
The third aspect of an athlete
is your mental fitness.
And this is one that I would
say on my national weekends,
my MotoAmerica weekends when
I'm working with riders,
it's the number one thing I
work on is their mental fitness.
Because they've done all
the hard work at that point.
They're there, right?
They've qualified
or whatever it is.
But now, how fit
they are mentally,
that's actually the tough one.
And the better your
mental fitness is,
the more you're going to be
able to access your technique as
well.
So if your mental fitness isn't
there for whatever reason,
you wake up one morning
and you get some bad news,
or whatever-- you
got a flat tire--
whatever the issue is, and now,
your mental fitness is blocked,
you're not going to be able
to access your technique.
I've got a great peer group
that I work with, a peer group.
The nice thing about
this peer group
is these are all people
that have come together
through motorcycles.
And the peer group
that I work with,
I've got some people
in high academics.
I have the number
one tactical trainer
in the country as
part of my group.
And also, I've got a person
that's a "Top Gun" fighter
pilot.
And they work so much
on the mental aspect
of what they do because you
need to be able to access
that information on demand.
So it's being able
to compartmentalize
what you're doing, your
technique, your craft,
and being able to
access it whenever you
want to be able to access it.
Because there's times where
you may not have a choice.
We'll talk about that
in just a minute.
So the three aspects
of an athlete--
your technique, your craft, what
you do, your physical fitness--
the fitter you
are, the longer you
can access this information.
So I can guarantee you--
and guys here that-- well,
anybody that's done
any type of sports.
Right?
As soon as your fitness
drops off, what happens?
Your focus drops off.
It's gone.
So that's why we work at being
very, very fit in our sport.
And then the other ones we
work on is our mental fitness.
We do a lot of things with our
mental fitness, whether it's--
we do a lot of visualization.
We do a lot of yoga.
We do a lot of
neuroscience work as well.
We've got some
pretty cool companies
that are on our side that work
on the neuroscience part of it.
So three aspects of
an athlete, man--
trying to be the
complete athlete
is really what
we're looking for.
So the second best practice
that I want to talk about.
And this is an interesting
one because for people
that don't ride motorcycles,
or are not into the sport,
it's why do we fall down?
Why do we fall down
on a motorcycle?
Right?
So there's really five reasons
why you crash a motorcycle.
And when I mean five
reasons, why we, we, me,
and these guys are
people that ride,
it's why we crash, the things
that we do on the motorcycle
to make it not stay upright.
There's lightning
strike crashes for sure,
where somebody may hit you, you
may have a mechanical issue,
whether somebody put oil on
the track or whatever it is.
There's those things as well.
But the five reasons why
we crash our motorcycles,
the five reasons why
we do something wrong--
and the first one is lack
of focus or lack of a plan,
lack of focus or lack of a
plan, not being in the moment.
Not being deliberate is
what it boils down to.
And typically, at these speeds--
I gave you some those
numbers, how fast
we go on some of these bikes.
Man, you just don't
have the time.
So not being in the
moment, not being
present to make that
happen, it literally
is the number one reason why
we're going to have issues.
And we'll talk about
some of the triggers that
allow that to happen, that
put your brain into gear.
Second one, abrupt inputs.
The faster you go, the more
lean angle you have to use.
So the smoother all of
your inputs have to be.
So abrupt inputs--
so you think about,
I have to be super aggressive
to go fast on a motorcycle.
It's completely the opposite.
So to go very, very
quick, you actually
have to be incredibly
smooth and very precise
with every input
on the motorcycle,
whether it's your
brake, or your throttle,
or your body movement.
Everything has to be just
absolutely, incredibly smooth.
So we have to work on being
smoother on all of our inputs.
The third reason why we crash is
what we call rushing direction.
What "direction" means
is on a motorcycle,
the quickest way around a
race track on a motorcycle
is to be able to hold the
throttle wide open the longest.
So the person that can hold the
throttle wide open the longest
is basically going to be
accelerating the most.
So the corners, unfortunately,
kind of get in the way of that.
So we have to learn how to place
our motorcycle on the entry
to get a better exit.
If we rush that placement,
if we rush bike placement,
if we rush where
that spot is, that's
the third reason why we crash.
Right?
You're actually putting the
wrong thing at the wrong time.
So rushing direction.
The fourth one's
repeating a mistake.
We have very deliberate
report cards in our riding.
And these report cards
tell us how we're doing.
So if there's a
track with 10 turns,
we literally have
10 opportunities
a lap to tell us
how we're doing.
And whether that's what the
direction of the motorcycle,
whether that's what control
we're using, whether we're
doing-- we have these report
cards available to us.
And the last reason why we
crash is funny because the ones
that I would say are the
most are one and this one.
So one is lack of
focus, lack of a plan.
This one's overconfidence.
Everything is working so great
that you can do no wrong.
And that's when [CLAPS]
not good things happen,
so overconfidence.
So how do these relate
to you, and your job,
and your regular work day?
So if you're going
to come to work,
we want to be success-based.
We don't want to
be failure-based.
Right?
So if you think about
it, if you come to work,
I would imagine you've
got a plan for your day.
Whether you're an individual
or you're a manager,
you're going to have some
sort of plan for the day.
There's nothing worse
than, obviously,
going through your day without
some sort of a plan for what
you're doing.
What that is, is
you've got to be
able to set your own
expectations as well
as your employees'
expectations as well.
So lack of focus,
lack of a plan.
Second one, abrupt inputs.
What "abrupt inputs"
simply means--
and this really works
well with the third one--
is rushing into a
situation without having
full knowledge of
what you're doing,
or not having all that
information available to you.
So abrupt inputs, What we
think about on our motorcycle
is the first 5% of our inputs
and the last 5% of our inputs.
Because the first 5%
is what sets you up
for the upcoming situation.
The last 5% gives you the fine
direction for that situation.
So the middle 90% is
completely adjustable,
based on whatever
the situation may be.
But if you start your
processes, you start your job,
you start whatever
your project is,
you think about the
first 5% of your project
so you're in a position to
adjust for the rest of it,
it will help you out a lot.
Same thing with the last 5%.
So the same thing with
rushing direction.
We talked a little
bit about that,
rushing direction,
which is constantly
thinking about what
direction you're going
and how you're getting there.
And we're going to work on
that one a little bit more.
Repeating a mistake--
fourth reason why we crash
is repeating a mistake.
Right?
You think about
one of the things
that the special forces
guys talk about is once is
a mistake, twice is a habit.
So you think about it that way.
And I'll give you a
quick story on that,
that some of these
special forces guys,
depending what group
they're in, they
have to qualify for their
shooting once a quarter.
So they have to qualify.
They go into a room
similar to this.
And they have to
shoot a certain thing.
And they don't know what it is.
They're told, hey, they got
to shoot this, this, or this.
So if they miss once--
they miss once-- they're
basically on probation.
They get docked pay.
They miss twice, they
got to find a new job.
So of course, we don't have
those kind of qualifications
here in this type
of environment.
They're degree of application
is a little bit different.
But to give you an
idea of why we're
taking a look about
repeating a mistake--
so repeating a mistake, we start
doing them over and over again.
It's absolutely a habit.
And we want to be able
to fix those things.
And the last one's
overconfidence.
The reason you feel
confident is because all
of the things you did right.
So if we can work on, OK, got
to fight that emotion and work
on that technique
that got you there.
So technical versus emotional.
We'll talk a little bit more
about that as well and what
a big deal that ends up being.
So that's the five
reasons why you crash.
And you can think about how
that relates to you, and even
in your job every day.
That's something that
I think about just
in my own life every day,
five reasons why I crash.
So the next one that
I want to talk about
is a different way of thinking.
And you can think, OK,
how do we get focus?
How do we get our
technique engaged?
And where that comes
from is our eyes.
So if your eyes are engaged,
your technique is engaged.
Think about that.
Right?
So if you're looking
at your situation,
you want to see what's going
on, our eyes have to be engaged.
More importantly than
that on our motorcycle is
our eyes have got
to be able to scan.
So if your eyes
are fixed, you'll
lose perspective of where
you're going or where you're at.
So it's no different than-- you
can take whatever your job is,
or whatever project
you're working on.
Right?
If you're just so
focused on this picture
here in front of you,
you lose perspective
of what's out there, just as if
you're only worried about that,
you're going to lose the
fine detail right here.
You've got to do both.
So you've got to be
able to think about,
what is it going to take
to get my eyes engaged
so I see both those things?
And that's what we do is
we have our eyes to scan.
Our eyes scan back and forth.
And in motorcycles, we've
got very specific triggers
for that.
As we decelerate,
our eyes move in.
As we accelerate,
our eyes move out.
So think about how we
get our eyes engaged.
And what are your-- do you have
reference points for your days?
Do you have reference
points for how you're doing?
Establishing some
reference points.
The motorcycle, we have five
established reference points
for every corner.
There's all this stuff going on.
You see a ton of things
in your peripheral vision.
But with our motorcycle, we
have five established reference
points.
We look at our exit apex,
our entry apex, or slowest
point of the corner,
our turning point,
and where we go to the brakes.
So that's it, five.
So yes, there's all these
other peripheral things
that are going
on, but we're only
focused on those five points.
And within those
five points, we're
only focused on one single
vital point for every corner.
Because if you hit one single
vital point for every corner,
the rest of them will
take care of themselves.
So it's identifying one, what
are those reference points?
And then the second
one is identifying
what the most vital one is.
Find that out in your own deal.
Right?
Find that out in your own jobs.
Find that out.
What is your most
critical reference point?
What are your reference points?
What is my end goal?
What is my short-term goal?
And how are my eyes
doing to connect those?
If I'm at my entry
apex, I'm going
to look out to my exit apex.
And I want to make sure that
my trajectory is straight.
So using your eyes
and your ability
to line those things up and
keep those continually moving,
it just helps bring
things together.
So that's what we
want to look at.
And you can ask yourself.
One of the trigger words
that I have for myself
is I ask myself, how am I doing?
How am I doing?
What are my report
cards for that?
So again, give yourself
some report cards.
Whether it's for the hour,
whether it's for the day,
know how you're doing.
Establish those
things for the day.
Something that we do
also with motorcycles
that's a little bit different--
we do it with some of the
car instruction as well.
I do some car
instruction as well--
is we draw the track backwards.
So in other words, we
draw the corner backwards.
We draw the situation
backwards because the reason
that we want to do that is we
know where we want to end up.
Right?
We want to end up out there.
But we want to
get there the most
efficiently way that we can.
So we'll draw the
corner backwards.
And one of the things
that I said to you
is what lasts longest
on a motorcycle, which
is acceleration.
So I'm trying to put
my acceleration zone
as early as possible because I
know that's what lasts longest.
So again, thinking
about it in your deals.
If you're working on 10
different things at once--
probably a lot more than that.
But if you're working
on 10 things at once
and four or five of them
really aren't that important--
you concentrate
on the things that
do make a difference, those
bigger vital points that make
a bigger part of that picture.
Yeah, you still got to address
some of those smaller points.
But which ones make
the biggest difference
for the longest period of time?
So we draw the track backwards
to be able to do that.
We want to know where
we're going to end up
and what our end goal is.
And everything adjusts to that.
We also look at our sport
a little bit differently.
And we look at
our sport as time.
We look at it as
feet per second.
We don't look at it as speed.
And the reason that
that is important
is the faster you go, the
less time you have available.
So if you have less
time available,
you have to be able
to adjust for that.
So it all goes back to
your initial inputs,
like I was talking
about, how you're
able to adjust those things.
So the faster you go, the
less time you have available.
And you have to be able to
adjust for those things.
So how are you able to adjust?
And how are you able to
put those things into play?
So something to
think about when it
comes to feet per second, and
time, and how we draw things
backwards.
So all right, so I
want to talk about--
this is kind of a fun one.
And this is one that
we've messed around
with quite a bit,
which is a proactive
versus reactive thinking
process, proactive
versus reactive.
And realize that you're
training for proactive,
and reactive is
actually the same.
It's the same
thing, being that--
and I can take it
a quick example.
2 times 2.
4 jump into your head?
Right?
Now, if we goes 7 times 9.
Did it take a millisecond
longer for that
to jump into your head?
Right?
Because you haven't trained
for that one as much,
though the process is identical.
So proactive
decision-making process
is having the time available
to make a decision.
That's really what we
all want, a proactive.
Right?
I want to have time
available to make
the best educated decision
for the situation that's
happening in front of me.
Of course, how do we see that?
With her eyes.
Right?
We talked about
that as well, being
able to see the
situation sooner.
So proactive is seeing
the situation early,
using all the data
that's in front of you,
and being able to make the
best educated guess for that
that's based on your training.
So what's a reactive
decision-making process?
Reactive is not having the time
available to make a decision,
and you have to default
to your training.
Remember, you're
going to default
to whatever your highest
level of training is.
That's what it boils down to.
So whatever your highest
level of training is,
that's what you're
going to default to.
So that's why we look at,
what are all of our risks?
And that's the things
that we train for.
If my motorcycle is
starting to slide,
I want to have something in my
tank, something in my toolbox
that allows me to
adjust for that.
Or my brakes start to fade.
I want to have something
available to be
able to adjust
for that, whatever
the different situation is.
So proactive thought process
versus a reactive thought
process, the training
is identical.
It's just being
able to understand
how you're going to
mitigate those risks,
understanding what those risks
are, and training for them.
So one thing that
tags along with that--
and I think this is
something that whether you're
an individual here, whether
you're a manager here,
something that works
is realize focus
is actually super easy to get.
Focus is great.
Focus is you get to
work in the morning.
Like, dude, I am going to
jump on that, and I am good.
And then whatever happens--
somebody comes by, drops a
load of stuff on your desk,
and then you're
completely unfocused.
Focus is very easy.
It's the refocus
that's the hard part.
So what we work on--
and again, motorcycle
racing, you
saw a little bit in that video.
You come up on a rider,
and you're inches apart,
going 100-and-some-odd
miles an hour.
And he makes a little bobble.
Something happens.
And you lose your
train of thought.
So we work on having
trigger words,
or trigger responses, to
put us back in the moment.
Focus is easy.
So my focus trigger is when
I roll out of hot pits,
I stand up on my foot pegs.
I sit back down.
I am focused.
I'm in the moment.
I am only worried
about my task at hand.
That's it.
We have other riders.
We have other riders that
wiggle their fingers.
Valentino Rossi,
nine-time world champion,
goes up to his motorcycle,
leans next to it.
He stands next to his foot peg.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter how
much time is available.
He's going to be a professional.
Professionals are predictable.
Right?
They're predictable
because they want
to take the same fundamental
and make it more fine.
So that's what Rossi is
going to be able to do.
So he's putting
his plan into play.
He's being focused.
Refocus is the tough one.
So finding a refocus
word, finding a refocus
trigger to put you
back in the game, that
is really the
secret sauce when it
comes to a lot of these things.
I spend a lot of time--
I do yoga.
I do Bikram yoga,
because, of course,
I wanted the most
difficult, gross, nasty one
that I could do so I do Bikram.
And I found out that when
my eyes weren't engaged,
guess what?
I'd fall out.
I'd fall out of my pose.
So I worked really hard
on my initial focus.
And then I worked
hard on my refocus.
And as soon as I feel myself
slipping out of a pose,
something's not right, then
I have a retrigger word.
My retrigger word's "eyes."
As soon as my eyes are
engaged, guess what?
It goes back to what I said.
Your focus is engaged.
Your technique is engaged.
So my refocus word is "eyes."
Even if it is just
jumping my eyes up,
even on the race track,
if something happens,
I jump my eyes to the
next reference point.
So that gets my
technique reengaged.
So proactive or reactive
thought processes,
give you a little something on
that, and then also the focus
and refocus, so some pretty
good things on that one.
So I have one last one, and
we'll do a little bit of a Q&A.
And then I have
something that I want
to talk to everybody
about, just real quickly.
This is one that
I've used for years,
whether it was I was
in the car business,
whether I use it with my riders.
And we do downloads quite
a bit with our riders
because we actually get
very little time to ride.
And this is why we do so many
things off the motorcycle.
Think about it because riding--
Dan, how many times have
you ridden this year?
SPEAKER: Seven weekends.
KEN HILL: Seven
weekends, six weekends.
Right?
So when you think about that,
how much time and effort
he's got to invest
in the sport, he
actually gets very
little time to do it.
Tracks are crazy expensive.
The bikes, everything's
expensive to do it.
So you have to
consolidate your time.
So this is why we
spend a lot of time
off the bike thinking about
all the different things
that we do so we can
go and not waste time
when we're there at the track.
So what we work on--
and this is something that
managers, this is a big deal.
You can ask her employees.
We ask them, what's
holding you back?
What's holding
you back the most?
So the rider might
come in, right?
The rider comes in, and
what ends up happening
is the crew chief runs over.
He's got his clipboard there.
The data guy comes
over with his laptop.
They're downloading all
the data out of the bike.
And their job is to essentially
find something wrong.
Right?
What's wrong?
We want to make you better.
We want your lap
time to get better.
We want to beat everybody else.
And so there's so much
information out there.
So we go through
our download sheet.
We do it every time that
we go out, when we ride.
And out of all things we go
through, at the very end of it,
we ask our rider, what's
the one single thing that's
holding you back the most?
And there's times
the rider may say--
and this happens
more often than not.
The rider will say, it's me.
I'm not focused.
I'm not doing a good job.
Don't touch the bike.
Let me come up to speed.
Let me get myself tuned up.
That's what's holding him
back, just as we've also
seen the rider come
in and go, hey,
we just try a new pair of forks.
I can't ride the
bike to my ability
because the bike
is holding me back.
But asking him, what is
holding you back the most?
That one right there?
That's something again in my
personal life, regular life
off the track,
I'm asking myself,
what's holding me back the most
from wanting to meet my goals?
So that is a really good one.
Another thought on that one is--
especially for engineers,
something to think about.
You guys are great on data.
You're fantastic.
Right?
Data pretty much never lies
as long as the data is pure.
One thing to think about--
stop negotiating with yourself.
Stop negotiating with yourself.
And what that simply means
is, look at the data,
look at the facts,
and act on it.
We get too much chatter
that's going on,
too much things
that are going on.
And if you can stop negotiating
with yourself-- this is
something that we find
out with riders a lot,
more on the mental side,
is whether they're not
good enough, they
haven't trained enough,
or whatever the issues are.
And so riders, as
we get them, we
say, look let's look at
our technical side of it,
not our emotional side of it.
If you take the emotion
out and you work just
on your technique,
man, things absolutely
start to happen that way.
So you can ask yourself, what's
holding you back the most?
And I think that that
is a really great one
that, again, in your own
situations, you can look at.
Managers, ask that
to your employees.
Ask that to the
people in your group.
Right?
What's holding
you back the most?
What can I do?
What can I do to unblock that?
What can I do to make your job
better or situation better?
Individual contributors, you
can think about that as well.
Right?
What's holding me back that
I need to convey to my team
so I can do a better job?
What's holding
you back the most?
Pick that one single
thing and work on that.
A couple of things that I
mentioned before is everybody
here comes at a
pretty high level.
But we look at look
at things differently,
where we talk about
professionals versus amateurs.
Right?
Professionals--
we all have goals.
Right?
I mean, as professionals,
we have goals.
Amateurs we have goals.
The difference is,
professionals have
processes to meet those goals.
Right?
Amateurs just have the goal.
I hope I get there.
Hope that works.
So think about professionals.
Right?
Professionals have processes.
Professionals are predictable
when it comes to those things.
So another thing,
a couple of things
I want to just talk
a little bit about
was training versus practice.
Realize that
training and practice
are two different things.
Right, you train to
learn something new.
You practice your training.
You practice those
situations to make it better.
So that's really about
all I have to give you
guys some good best practices.
I know, of course,
I talked too long.
Sorry, Dan.
It works that way.
I can take some
questions if people
have any questions on some of
the things that I talked about.
I'm hoping that I gave you
a little bit of something
that you can think about,
whether it's your motorcycle
riders, or whether it's
part of your regular day.
And again, you wanted
some of the things
that riders do, riders in a
world-class environment, riders
that are the best
at what they do.
These are things that they look
at every day in their life.
Whether it's on the
bike or off the bike,
these are the types of
habits that they look at
to get themselves to
be the best there is.
So I hope you all enjoyed it.
If you've got questions,
I'll take them.
AUDIENCE: This might be-- it's
just specifically about bikes
or not.
But I just started tracking
again and got a new vehicle.
It was a 675R with
Ohlins, stalk, everything.
KEN HILL: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Should
have been great.
I got to the track.
They almost didn't let me
on tech-inspection-wise
because the front
forks were too stiff.
I think it scared them.
And I went over to
Evolution and had them look
at it, et cetera, et cetera.
But applying this, this fell
outside of my competency.
I didn't know what was wrong.
And I don't know.
Sometimes maybe in life, or--
this danger was something
that if that guy hadn't--
KEN HILL: Did you
buy the bike new?
AUDIENCE: No.
But it had 2,000 miles
on it, one owner.
KEN HILL: Yeah.
And this is great.
I mean, that's actually
a great question.
And again, it absolutely works
in the rest of your life.
Right?
So if you people
that are engineers,
things work in an envelope.
Right?
There is an absolute operating
envelope of how things work.
And a bike of that caliber--
that's an amazing motorcycle.
I've got a bunch of
time on those bikes.
They're a fantastic bike.
But one of the
things that you can
do before you ride that
bike is understand,
if you bought the bike
new, you know its history.
Right?
You already know.
You can look in the manual
and see where things are.
Bikes that you don't
know the history,
I absolutely will spec them out.
So find out where the bike is.
Find out who's been in there.
Find out where the
bike is, because it has
so many different adjustments.
The main thing is
finding out where
you're working at, where
the bike is in its operating
envelope.
That's something that
we work with, again,
on a very high level with
suspension engineers,
data engineers, all
the electronics that
are on the bike is,
as a rider starts
to have a preference
for something,
we want to see if he's staying
within the actual operating
parameters of where the
bike is working the best.
So in your case on yours,
I'd get the bike specced out,
find out where the bike is.
And also, the problem with
that is feel means nothing.
I mean, if you
bounce on the bike,
I mean, you can have
some ideas of it.
But for the most
part, until you know
where the premolars of the bike
are, until you've specced it
out, I wouldn't make that
call because bikes feel--
If you look at my personal bike,
the forks feel really soft,
the back is a brick.
The back is super stiff.
So somebody would look at
that and go, oh, my god,
it's not ridable.
But in fact, it is
very, very ridable.
So yeah, get it specced out.
AUDIENCE: So specifically, not
a lot of suspension shops--
I mean, who do you go to
find out if a track bike
suspension is OK in this area?
Ken Moss might be--
SPEAKER: Dave Moss.
AUDIENCE: Dave Moss, sorry.
KEN HILL: Yeah,
so again, so part
of what I've worked
on in all my life
is, I want to do what the
best riders in the world
are doing because if there was
a better way, they would do it.
Pretty simple.
Right So realize that
person that I'm going to ask
is somebody that has operated
at that highest level.
I use Mike Canfield
in Sacramento.
And I do just because he's
four-time MotoAmerica crew
chief.
And he's got his own
suspension shop there.
So I'll use somebody
like him because, I mean,
I want to work
with somebody that
has operated at the very highest
levels because they understand.
Something we also talk about--
if you want the last
1%, it has to come
from somebody that
understands the last 1%,
where in your case, that
may be your last 1%.
It may not be his last 1%.
But he's still at a point
where he can understand it.
So does that makes sense?
OK, good.
What other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm not a rider.
But this is more
of, like, a question
for that pertains to sport
and training and all that.
If you're trying to get to the
next level, or training for--
I don't know-- a new technique,
or specifically, say,
in riding, when there's
very little room for error,
how do you make that
progress and not
have a really, really
bad consequence?
KEN HILL: Yeah, so we talk about
how we build new fundamentals.
And honestly, and when we're
looking at it from a risk
standpoint because riding
a motorcycle, of course,
can be very risky.
And it's like dude, Scott,
yeah, just go in there
and send the thing in there.
You'll be fine.
It doesn't work that way.
So we work on taking things at
a very precise and deliberate
stepping level.
So for instance, if we
have a rider that's--
we want him to brake
later into a corner
because getting into
a corner or braking
later is probably the scariest
thing on a motorcycle.
Your fear factor takes over.
Instead of saying,
hey, look, you
need to go to the
brakes 200 feet later,
how about you go to the
brakes 10 feet later.
And then you work up to it.
So it's just like
in different sports.
Cycling is the same way for me.
So as a cyclist, a fairly
competitive cyclist,
in my training, we
would train with power.
It's the same thing, right?
If I want a certain
power increase,
I'm just not going to
expect a huge increase.
Instead, I'll build my
training incrementally
to be able to get there.
And of course,
you've got to have
good data to be able
to support that as well
and have pure data to be
able to make that happen.
So we'll look at things
and step them up.
But again, you have
to put yourself
in a position to be able
to adjust for it as well.
So this goes all back to
all of your initial inputs
have got to be smooth so we
can have that clear data.
Also being able to
record that data
is a pretty big deal as well.
We do a lot of work with video.
Video works good for us.
But we also do a lot of data
acquisition work as well.
And then I was using
the cycling analogy.
Same thing, we use a
lot of data on cycling
to track power levels.
So when we're building a new
habit or a new fundamental,
one, we work on one
thing at a time.
Because if you want 100%
result from something,
you work on one thing at
a time, instead of working
on 10 different things at 10%.
So we'll spend a massive
amount of time working
on that one very single thing.
I have a rider, for instance--
actually, I'll give
you two examples.
I have a rider that we worked
on their initial brake control
for probably six months, just
on how he went to the brakes.
And not only would we
practice it on the bike,
but we'd practice it in his car.
So even if he was working on the
motorcycle, I needed the brain,
I needed the
electrical connection
in his brain to not be
aggressive with his inputs.
So how he drove his car, I'd
be very deliberate on how
he went to the brakes.
And that really sped
that process up.
Another way of shortcutting that
process is exactly what I said.
Whatever your sport is,
whatever that habit is,
you can work on it off of it.
I mentioned yoga.
So one of the things
that I work on in yoga
is I work on the
first 5% of my pose
because one, being a
dumb male, I typically
do things way too aggressively.
If I notice that I got
into a pose too quickly,
I'd fall out of
the pose earlier.
But if I got into the pose, the
first 5% of my pose was slower,
I could almost always hold
the pose the whole minute.
So it's putting all these
things in your brain that,
again, how you do anything
is how you do everything.
So a good thought for you there.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Any
recommended reading?
KEN HILL: Yeah,
with the reading,
I don't have anything
reading-wise that I do.
I mean, I read a lot of
books on essentially just
basic psychology, things
along those lines,
just how brains work.
But I don't really have
any recommended reading
other than doing what the
best in the world are doing.
So I spent a lot, like
the fighter pilot stuff.
There's a lot of stuff
on how the fighter
pilots look at things, even
the special forces guys.
I look at a lot of
that type of reading
and the psychology
that goes behind it.
All right, thanks,
everyone, for coming.
Appreciate it.
Good.
[APPLAUSE]